[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à new delhi la reine elizabeth a connu
son plus grand succès de foule depuis
son arrivée en inde près de 3 millions
de personnes 10 tôt en compagnie du
prince philippe du président héros et
des plus hautes personnalités de l'inde
la reine d'angleterre assistait à la
gigantesque parade militaire destinée à
marquer le 11e anniversaire de la
proclamation de la république indienne
si tu vends colonie de la couronne
britannique parade militaire
impressionnante mais moins sans doute à
cause des blindés et autres armes
modernes en raison de la couleur locale
qui imprègne cette armée
[Musique]
un taux aux éléphants de parade aux
délégations des anciens royaumes et des
tribunes lointaine ils appartiennent
désormais au folklore
[Musique]
le premier britannique lui a passé le
week end à rambouillet où il était
l'hôte avec son épouse du général et de
madame de gaulle pas d'ordre du jour ni
de communiqué officiel mais on imagine
aisément les thèmes de ses entretiens au
coin du feu comme on les a appelés
l'europe bien sûr et surtout les
rapports est ouest dont l'installation à
la maison blanche du président kennedy
va pour une part conditionné l'évolution
[Musique]
oh
si les robes sont encore aux secrets du
moins les couturiers laisse voir les
chapeaux chez lanvin qu'un stylo un
abat-jour de paille que présente
vedettes de l'actualité produits
mannequin vedette sylvia casabianca chez
jacques griffe est un an de cloche de
plume de vautours que porte marie
thérèse chez jacques aymes capeline à
double usage que portait diana chez
michel goba une élégante architecture de
paris que porte ginai
[Musique]
oh
chez pierre balmain c'est au contraire
la réduction qui prévaut compenser il
est vrai par l'ampleur de la voilette
[Musique]
montreuil ou chapeau on peut se poser la
question à propos de ce modèle présenté
par renata chez jean de cesse et qui
répond au nom parfaitement adéquat de
foin coupé
[Musique]
quant au modèle que porte nathalie chez
pierre cardin il tient du suroît pour la
forme et de la gaufrette pour la matière
voici les chapeaux ils sont étonnants
attendant la suite
pour sauver les temples tombeau de
ramsès ii abou simbel
l'unesco a lancé un appel au secours en
effet la construction du barrage
d'assouan fera monter de 62 mètres les
eaux du nil qui engloutiront alors ce
patrimoine de l'humanité
un projet français prévoit la
construction d'une doute semi-circulaire
vote de 70 m appelant très incliné
entourant un miroir d'eau ce projet
aurait l'inconvénient de supprimer à
tout jamais l'entrée du soleil levant
qui venait caresser vos fins du tombeau
la statue d'osiris un autre projet d'une
audace stupéfiante consiste à décapiter
d'abord la falaise dans laquelle sont
creusées les deux temps puis à découper
l'europe autour et sous les tempes a
entouré les deux cubes d'une structure
protectrice en béton armé puis par le
jeu de quelques 300 vérins hydrauliques
à élever leurs 300 mille tonnes jusqu'au
niveau du lac futur il serait ensuite
recouvert de rochers pour retrouver leur
ancien silhouette devant les eaux du nil
l'unesco incline vers ce projet a redit
reste l'acceptation de l'egypte et la
question d'argent
[Musique]
sans cesse croissant les besoins
d'énergie oblige à rechercher de
nouvelles sources de production
c'est ainsi que des conduites venue de
lacq passe désormais par la centrale
moderne de montereau le gaz d'aquitaine
relaye le charbon dans l'alimentation de
cette usine qu'un seul technicien suffit
à conduire et où la télévision permet de
suivre la combustion à l'intérieur même
des chaudier
près de chinon s'édifie la centrale
d'avoine c'est l'énergie nucléaire qu'on
va mettre à contribution pour la
production d'électricité
plaçant ainsi la france aux côtés des
nations envoi d'équipement dans ce
domaine
[Musique]
un vestiaire de la rance enfin la mer
sera bientôt domestiques et les travaux
qui doivent aboutir à la centrale
marémotrice sont activement poussé
depuis les expériences probantes mené
avec un groupe décès sur place
utilisant l'énergie des marées dans
quelques mois la france disposera donc
de la première usine marémotrice du
monde
le mouvement des marées puissant
potentiel d'énergie jusqu'ici inemployée
entrera ainsi au service des hommes
[Musique]
si l'on mesure le degré de civilisation
des nations modernes à la quantité
d'énergie elle était consommée par leurs
habitants
nul doute que la france puisse faire
confiance à son avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et d'attendre démonstration des petites
cylindrées cette année au rallye de
monte-carlo autrement dit avec la petite
voiture pas chère de monsieur tout le
monde
on peut se permettre d'aller aussi vite
et avec autant de sécurité que les
grosses dévoreuse de carburant au long
capot sur des routes particulièrement
difficile comme vous pouvez en juge
la neige n'est qu'un des moindres
traquenard du 30e rallye de monte carlo
il y a également le verglas les nuits
sans sommeil et puis aussi un petit
rayon de soleil très bref cependant à
l'arrivée à monaco
tapie revient bien vite juste pour le
départ de l'épreuve de vitesse pas de
répit pour les pilotes
la tradition veut que le rallye se
déroule dans des conditions très
difficiles
elles sont encore respecté cette année
seulement pour les grosses voitures
d'essayer de rattraper un retard acquis
sur les boutons au fil des kilomètres
les pilotes ne sont pas les seuls à
faire preuve d'audace puis les an plus
tôt on a tous les courages sur la côte
d'azur
et
si la part belle 17 des gagnants encore
bon pied bon oeil après plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres ce sont trois pas
rare qu'ils prennent les trois premières
places pouvant ainsi que les petites
cylindrées qui sont sans complexes
peuvent encore faire mieux que les
groupes
[Musique]
c'est de la main des grâces que les
vainqueurs maurice martin et roger
bateau reçoivent leurs récompenses
[Musique]
l'hippodrome de vincennes à l'heure de
la vérité c'est-à-dire au départ du
grand prix d'amérique
paradoxe pas un cheval américains dans
ce grand prix d'amérique qui est
pourtant la plus grande course du monde
de trot attelé
pas de cheval américain mais parmi les
grands cracks une coquette jumeaux
normande pas encore très connue du grand
public elle a tout juste cinq ans et
elle se nomme masina pour acheter cette
jument prodige son propriétaire a tout
vendu il s'est débarrassé de ses boeufs
et de ses pairs et il a bien fait en
définitive masina vous allez la voir
c'est un boulet de canon après s'être un
instant perdu dans le peloton elle
attaque la ligne droite en troisième
position très féminine elle porte un
coquet petit bibi tout blanc elle
ridiculise tous les mâles dans les
derniers 100 mètres et elle rapporte par
la même occasion 20 millions à son
propriétaire qui ne regrette pas les
sacrifices qu'il a consentis pour elle
[Applaudissements]
après ses victoires du lauberhorn et de
la nonne gamme guy périllat va-t-il
réussir dans la coupe emile allais le
triplé qui ferait de lui un phénomène
unique dans l'histoire du ski alpin
malgré la présence de zimmermann et
surtout d'adrien du vieillard qui
l'année dernière à bessat le record de
la piste un temps apparemment tabac
table et qui est lui aussi un adepte du
vj la fameuse position française de vitz
[Musique]
le grand jour
le soleil a ramené le sourire des
mygales au départ bozon la qualité
exceptionnelle de la neige a rendu la
piste meurtrière au milieu du parcours
après avoir bien négocier le difficile
virage en s opposant aborde le mur du
born et ont rapidement éteint
[Musique]
ce virage en s et le mur du born et dont
la pente est de 60% sont aussi le
tombeau du champion allemand ludwig
klein teneur du champion italien des néo
colons et de 27 entre coureurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du bia numéro 9
c'est en partant que son record de l'an
passé a été battu de deux secondes par
l'autrichien zimmermann bien assuré sur
ses skis
ils attaquent impeccablement le virage
en s passe le mur du born et plus vite
que ne l'a fait périllat et battant
zimmermann
il prend la deuxième place
[Musique]
enfin guy périr admirable giesser il
attaque le schuss de l'alpe est et
absorbent ces bosses à 110 alain
sentant est déjà le meilleur au passage
de la maison forestière
[Musique]
il aborde le virage en s avec plus de
deux secondes d'avancé sur du billard et
ne dessine que deux virages dans le mur
du born et là où la plupart ont dessiné
quatre et même cinq vira déjà le
meilleur aux deux tiers du parcours
périllat à plus de 110 à leur aborde le
schuss d'arrivée pourtant hérissée de
bost guy périllat a réussi un triplé qui
en fait un véritable champion du monde
dans deux minutes 29 secondes 5/10
moyenne 84 kilomètres heure contre 70
km/heure en 1952 par tony s'aiment
[Musique]